robert lawrence kuhn is a veritable
truth seeker
and much of the modern proliferation of
analytical and intellectual discourse in
video form into consciousness into the
origins of the universe into the
relationship between both
is due to his wonderful series closer to
truth
it's likely that you've seen his show
many times and even if you can't place
his name
robert lawrence kuhn you'll likely be
able to place his face this episode is a
dive into the nature of truth
so for example how do you know if you're
getting closer to it if you can't define
it as well as faith
as well as logic as well as god if
you're new to this channel my name is
kirch i mungle
i'm interested in what are called
theories of everything which is a
physics terminology
it means the unification of gravity with
quantum field theory but it also has
other philosophical meanings
and so i'm trying to explore the
variegated theories of everything
because there are about 200 or so
if you enjoy seeing conversations like
this and you would like to hear
see more then please do consider
supporting at patreon.com next
30 days will be quite the unconscionable
slog
for me because i'm interviewing chris
langan that comes
toward the end of june chris langan is
the person who's been characterized as
having the highest iq in america
and he has a theory of everything called
the cognitive theoretic model of the
universe
that's for later in june later in june
as well as rupert spira
daniel schmattenberger if i'm
pronouncing his name right
in this month may i have chomsky coming
up bernardo castro and john verveiki
are coming on again for round two of a
theo locution
at the end of may i'm also speaking to
stephen wolfram on his theory of
everything
as well as luis elizondo on ufos there's
also a secret project being planned with
yoshibak which
i think you may be extremely excited for
all of this takes a tremendous
tremendous amount of work
because what i'd like to do in these
podcasts is not give an overview but
instead
to go deep into certain subjects and
that
requires me to read their papers and
sometimes
chris langens for example is extremely
oblique and
opaque at least to me which means that
studying for it is
well it's difficult as well as rupert's
spirit is going to be quite
a challenge i try to over prepare for
virtually each topic except
ufos because ufos is one that i'm wholly
unacquainted in so most of the time when
i'm speaking to someone on the topic of
aliens or ufos
i'm speaking as a beginner for example
to kevin knuth or
to jeremy corbell and to a lesser extent
avi lope because
that was more physics based we also have
a paypal if you're more interested in
that and in fact more of the money the
percentage-wise goes to
the creator that is me if you donate or
support using the paypal link
that's in the description thank you so
much thank you regardless of your
decision
i hope you enjoy this episode you don't
generally say yes to interviews
i was wondering why you said yes to this
one
at least interviews not about china i
think we've we've had a
a change with the internet uh closer to
truth has had a
a spectacular year uh some of it
energized by of course the lockdown but
it's been continuing
at uh on our youtube channel a five-fold
increase
um over the last year and we've
appreciated and i've appreciated the
thousands of comments that we've had uh
foreclosure to truth
and a lot of them have asked you know
they like my questions but they'd like
to see some of my answers i do some
um commentary on our shows
um with interstitial commentary
and an open and a close particularly a
close but on
the vast majority of our interviews i'm
just literally asking questions so
a number of an increasing number of uh
of uh viewers uh for the closer-to-truth
uh youtube channel have been asking for
my opinion and things and
and a number of people have asked for
interviews so i've sort of changed our
policy uh
we've had a uh kind of a laser focus
on producing closer to truth uh i've
been doing this for 20 years
but uh really non-stop since 2006 when
uh peter getzells
uh joined forces with me as an
award-winning
director producer very knowledgeable
about science
um and since that time it's been it's
been a just a tremendous
exciting um productions and then doing
shows and so that
all of my energies was devoted to that
um
and when we produce a show
in previously interviews they're pretty
much raw interviews
much like this they're shorter focused
on an individual question will last
will last for seven to ten
eleven minutes uh and then it's on to
the next when we work with an individual
uh such as you've had donald hoffman or
robbie loeb uh
we might have a session of 10 or 12 or
15
of those eight to ten minute segments
and that's what we do and we post those
uh but then when we do our actual show
we don't spend an enormous amount of
time
uh worrying about every frame and every
word and to get it get it right
um and so that's been totally
consumptive um
and so i i i i wanted to devote
all of my energies to producing the best
thought and the best uh
presentation for uh for
the topics that we deal with which i'm
sure we'll discuss in great detail
but as i said in the last year because
closer to truth has now
been using the youtube channel
and has broadened itself internationally
because we're on pbs television for 20
years
obviously our focus was in the u.s so
while when our youtube channel started
was like 95
u.s audiences and we've been happy to
see that percentage drop and drop and
drop
and so now we're about forty percent u.s
so sixty percent plus
outside the us um with um some
very significant um demographics uh
in in just very broadly in the world and
so all of that
has contributed to kind of a rethinking
and so
i rather than
um just focus entirely on producing our
shows
uh wanted to respond to the uh
to the times and to our audience uh to
really get behind this scenes and and
just uh you know see me as a kind of a
normal person who has the same
kinds of questions and interests that
many of our audience does and so that's
why i'm
i'm pleased to do it obviously we screen
and and i think the professionalism by
which you and some others
uh have uh have brought to uh questions
involving science um each with its own
particular orientation which is fine um
i i would look and peter and i would
would uh
analyze the um the
compatibility with what we want to do
for closer to truth so
there is a level of sophistication
and seriousness uh not that we should
take ourselves seriously
but that we should take our topic
seriously and
um and do it without you know in a very
open manner
and so you know we've appreciated what
what you've done what you've created and
uh
happy to share our experiences
well firstly i thank you for the
compliment suggesting that i'm even
somewhat professional and sophisticated
i wouldn't categorize myself as that
i just for the people watching
robert's show closer to truth is the
highly professional version of this show
the highly
high production value in fact it's
better to say that
my show was the low budget version of
yours because yours was out 15 years
prior
so if you like theories of everything
this podcast you're going to love
closer to truth i recommend searching
closer to truth
i'm sure it's it will come up and robert
kuhn
if you search his name interviews with
him
as well closer to truth.com
closer to truth.com is our website and
our youtube channel you can search for
the youtube channel closer to truth
youtube channel those are our two main
uh vehicles other than of course the pbs
television show which is
broadcast on over 200 stations in the
u.s
are you still producing closer to truth
do you have ideas for future episodes
yes definitely uh definitely in fact
that's uh we're very excited about
uh um this year of course we we've not
uh we we've done post-production for
previous productions we've had we have a
new series coming out
in in a couple of months it's it's
almost entirely produced
uh 13 episodes we have 13 episodes in a
season
uh closer to truth works in seasons um
that doesn't mean one a year they'll be
buried there might be one a year might
be three a year normally is about one
and a half or two
uh 13 episodes um and we've done
20 13 um
episode season so far since our first
since the new version of closer to truth
began broadcasting in 2008 we've had 20
seasons of 13 episodes each actually the
last one was 10 episodes
and the new one coming out which is
season 21 will
focus on scientific breakthroughs and
we've um we've shot extensively
at the institute of advanced study in
princeton
and the santa fe institute in santa fe
new mexico
on complexity theory and have some just
wonderful interviews
for example uh um edward whitten
uh who we hadn't had before the leading
string theorist
uh very extensive interviews with him uh
and just a whole number of
terrific people uh at the institute
karen olenbach robert dygraf our
old friend paul davies is with us the s
ramachandran
uh antonio dimazio in areas of
scientific glenn milad now
we really have a terrific season and we
focus on scientific breakthroughs in
physics
and scientific breakthroughs in biology
and we break it into two parts one is
the concept what is a scientific
breakthrough in physics what
what is how can you account for it what
does it mean what kind of step function
is there
in understanding the concept of
breakthrough
um and secondly what is the process of
breakthrough so we have one whole show
on what is a breakthrough in physics
then another one
what is the process by which a
breakthrough in physics occurs
then we do the same thing in biology
those are two
so a number about six of the shows in
the new season will be on scientific
breakthroughs then we have some really
diverse
and interesting subjects so one is on
deception so we have some of the leading
theorists on the concept of descent
deception both in the animal kingdom
and in uh and in human beings in fact
one show was on deception and animals
one show was
on deception and human beings and then
two on uh music in the brain
and one on uh transhumanism and
what does it mean in in in brain science
so that's our new season coming up
um it'll be broadcast on pbs i said
within a few months uh starting um i
should mention though
that the first two episodes in the new
season
are a tribute to freeman dyson uh
freeman
was one of our early contributors
and enriched our show enormously and we
very much
appreciate it and so peter getzelz and i
put together a
a two-part tribute uh working with his
family
and so we have a lot of inside photos
and and ideas and then
most of the show of course is freeman's
own ideas um
and one of them will deal with his views
on on physics which is natural
and the other is sort of a broad his
broad approach to
to a lot of other things so it's a very
exciting
opening to the new season uh on on
freeman dyson
then going on from here we've used the
last year to look to the future
and we have a a pretty exciting backlog
of production uh which are fully funded
by
um
[Music]
excellent foundations with whom we work
the john templeton foundation the arthur
binding davis
foundation um the templeton religion
trust uh templeton world charity
foundation
um and so these series coming up um
and in no order of importance because
they're all important like which of your
children are the most exciting so don't
don't take it like the first one i
mentioned is most important but i just
want to
mention the ones that we'll be doing uh
productions in the future
the first is the global philosophy of
religion
uh and this is a very
not just exciting but we believe an
important uh
um project that is run
at the university of birmingham in the
uk
run by a closer to truth contributor and
one of our closest uh
allies and colleagues eugene nagazawa
who's
originally a philosopher of mind and has
become a leading philosopher of religion
and really a a wonderful philosopher and
thinker
we worked with eugene actually almost 10
years ago
in producing a series of programs on
alternative concepts of god
which are which were different ideas
than the traditional
judeo-christian islam monotheism
and those are very successful programs
and eugene has put together
a vision for engaging
the world because philosophy of religion
really has been
pretty much focused uh on the
judeo-christian religion particularly
christian philosophers
um and the work that has been done since
the middle ages in christian philosophy
is
really wonderful stuff some people and
scientists make fun of these kinds of
philosophies
and we can get into that um but uh
the contribution that the christian
philosophy has done over the years to
thinking about
about now they do it from their
perspective of course but
the ways of thinking are are really
wonderful and
expansionary for human human development
but
it is still christo-centric or
judeo-christo-centric which is what we
closer to truth has done just out of
expediency
right um we did reach out to try to get
um non-christian thinkers and we have in
the beginning we have
uh hussein nasser who's arguably one of
the leading islamic philosophers in the
world from
from iran persia uh tradition uh
and a wonderful philosopher and we have
some buddhists and hindus
but the skew was very much uh toward
a judeo-christian and so when eugene had
this project to really engage the whole
world
in um in in this endeavor in in terms of
expanding the thinking in philosophy of
religion
we jumped on and uh we said and worked
together with eugene and the john
templeton foundation we have it fully
funded so our
first program in this regard is actually
going to be an online conference which
will occur in june as a conference and
then thereafter
we will have about 20 interviews maybe
more
panel discussions keynotes that will
deal with the global philosophy of
religion and we will deal with
obviously um uh islam and hinduism
but we're going to go broader than that
we wanted to do uh
a sikh is we are doing sikhism and uh
african religions so we have a very
broad diversity of ideas so
global philosophy and religion is one
project for the future next year will be
in birmingham
live for our typical closer to truth um
productions very very high quality
shows will take a year or so to get out
on pbs and then youtube
uh it's a long process that we have but
but we love it and we're dedicated to it
other
other uh series coming up our philosophy
of biology
which is will be our first foray into
biology in a very serious way
and it will become a a new category for
close to the truth right now
quotes of truth classically has three
big categories cosmos
which deals with cosmology astronomy
physics mathematics um
consciousness which deals with brain
mind diverse intelligences
a little bit esp once in a while uh
um alien intelligences uh uh
personal alien intelligences as in ufo
aliens or just
extraterrestrial life what would they be
like no but
astrobiology basically and thinking
about what the nature of alien
intelligence is
um we deal with pers
how does personal identity uh be
maintained free will it's been a major
topic
that's our consciousness and then our
meaning category really is philosophy of
religion
um and it it heretofore has been
somewhat as i said
uh judeo-christian-centric and so what
we're looking to do is expand that
category
meaning uh and now with philosophy of
biology which is
one of our biggest grants and one of our
biggest productions
uh contemplated that will become a new
category of closer to truth called
life which we will develop in the future
other series coming up are a continuing
work on art seeking understanding and we
will
we have a wonderful opportunity with the
arthur binding davis foundation
in terms of eastern traditions which
will focus on buddhism
and chinese philosophy confucianism and
taoism
with big focus on buddhism and how those
those religions or traditions
deal with the big questions this is not
one-on-one religion about telling about
these religions that's not our job
we're going to focus on what are the big
questions that closer to truth asks
that we have traditionally approached
from a judeo-christian point of view
yeah and how do these other traditions
deal with those same questions so
we got we got a long future ahead of us
we just got to keep healthy robert just
so you know if i ever look angry
i'm just thinking that's my thinking
face i'm sure you're familiar with it
i don't mind i don't mind anger what i
what i mind is passivity
well you know whatever i do is fine but
no i i like anger
you know get angry at me you know okay
all right you mentioned that one of the
reasons you
stayed or steered clear from eastern
traditions before was expediency
and i'm also wondering if it's also due
to the
level of unfamiliarity that we in the
west we grow up with so for example
if a western philosopher thinks that the
jump from analytic philosophy to
continental is huge
try continental slash analytic to
eastern philosophy
it's a completely different base it's
almost meditative and experiential and
requires special knowledge insights that
you glean that you can't necessarily
share
so is that another reason why or is it
purely expediency
i i think well i i i expediency is not a
term i would use uh
because going in we wanted to do it we
wanted to get
first class philosophers but in our in
our
limited production because we weren't
using internet where we could interview
anybody anytime we were doing
and we do it close to very high
production value
um um videos and television
that are the the equivalent as we say of
toyota commercials and so we like to get
crews
peter gets directors of photography and
cameramen
between their toyota commute commercials
where they're paid
at rates where they're off time they'd
love closer to truth so they do it at
scale
and so we can afford it but still very
expensive and we have crews of you know
13 15 people
three cameras dollies jebs i mean it's a
big
effort and so the only way we can do
that efficiently
is to uh uh is to sort of uh a gang
tape within a week we do 15 because
people are gathered at a conference and
the kinds of conferences that we've had
because they've been limited have been
western oriented now a lot have been
physics we
work very closely with an organization
called fqxi
foundation questions institute uh
which deals with sort of over the
horizon physics and cosmology with
some of the leading uh cosmologists and
quantum physics
physics looking at um
the foundations of quantum mechanics
looking at uh
new ideas in cosmology um and so that's
what we have done
and it's just that in none of those
venues that we've had
would eastern philosophers at a first
grade level come up
now you bring up a very important point
in terms of the experiential aspect of
eastern philosophy
because we have a kind of an operating
framework on closer to truth that
experiential
work is something that we can refer to
but it's not
our core because you can't share it uh
because it is it is difficult
for third-party verification you know it
internally
so we we have had shows and efforts
saying
why an analytic philosophical approach
is not sufficient that's a fair
comment within everything but to then
adjudicate between uh
large numbers of uh of of of people
in in particular eastern traditions but
also in western traditions who have
experiential understanding and that's
part of their
their core we have determined that's not
within closer to truth's orbit
to deal with in detail and so that's
probably
a um an unintended
skew why we have not pursued eastern
religions
as much as we should because in eastern
religions there is
more of that experiential internal
dimension
uh but that excuse is uh is no longer
acceptable to us
yeah i was also thinking if you're
mentioning that there's a lack of third
party verification the same could be
said about consciousness but you have a
whole series on that
for example you can't tell if i'm
conscious i can't tell if you're
conscious
sure sure and and we deal with that very
very extensively as a very important
part of the consciousness uh approach
look
everybody has a bias my phd
is in neuroscience you can see some
stuff on the background remind myself
of my early days in neuroscience
so that that's a particular skew that
i've had
um in terms of a world view from
it's a scientific worldview it's a
neuroscience worldview at least that was
the
germinating aspect of my of my kind of
thinking
um so we have as i said recognize from
the beginning
the importance of eastern thinking and
we have that right from the beginning
like hosting
uh uh uh jose nasser
who was one of our first interviewees in
2007
i think um but we've not
we've not taken it further this year
with the expansion of closer to truth
globally
uh we've recognized that this is this is
an issue so we have made peter not made
a
focus uh to to uh
put our um our future approach in
um in to reach out and again our
audiences are now broader so that
they're pushing us as well
as rightly they should when we get
criticized um
in in uh feedback or youtube comments uh
that you should deal with eastern
religion what we now say is you know
we've done a little bit but you're right
you know that that's a missing dimension
that we have and we're gonna
we're going to fill it and we're you
know very pleased coincidentally um
that uh that yucha nagasawa has put
together this remarkable
global philosophy of religion project
which is you know very broad
sending a three-year project it has
three specific
content areas the first is on the
existence
and nature of deities and that was the
first
of the three big areas and that's what
our
first conference online conference will
be it was supposed to be in person
but we've now transferred it online the
second conference
will be on um death and immortality
so that will deal with consciousness
kinds of issues
and the third will be on problem of evil
suffering in the world those kinds of
things
so those are the three categories of to
to take a global philosophy of religion
and we're doing the first online the
second we'll do in person
and hopefully we can do something with
the third as well and that that will
really
uh broaden closer to truth where it
should go so
thanks to eugene and uh john templeton
foundation for their
their project and and eugene's project
has is much broader than these just
these conferences they have
research projects they're going to do
books it's it's a big effort
uh to create really a new field of
global philosophy of religion and
reaching out to
this as i've said african philosophy uh
sikhism shintoism we have a the leading
shinto philosopher eugene's gonna have
to translate
on the phone uh but we did we didn't
want to
sub optimize by getting a a philosopher
who speaks fluent english
we wanted to get the best philosopher
right
right right right and so in facintoism
uh the individual doesn't speak english
uh and so usually we'll
will translate he promises me not to put
any of his own ideas in but to translate
honestly robert how do you and peter
besides let's say technical logistics
how do you prepare for each interview
um the way we do closer to truth
normally and then i'll describe the last
year where we're doing it online
is that we have to have generally
minimum of five days
and maximum probably of seven in which
we will go to a location
uh for example we've we've done with
fqxi
we did it in vieques in puerto rico we
did it in iceland we did it in uh
um iceland was on cosmology vieques when
we did fqxi was in information theory
uh and in banff canada which was the
last one we did was on
physics of the observer and the physics
of what happens basically it's the
foundations of quantum mechanics so
let me just describe that in banff in
banff they had uh
i don't know 80 or so physicists who
came to this event um and we
we picked about 15 uh 17 15
who we shot within this six five six day
period
uh we did some on locations it's quite a
hectic schedule
man congrats it's it's very hard and it
doesn't happen easily
boot camp it's it's a very intense uh
uh seven eight days the navy has
something called hell week that sounds
like hell
seven no it's it's it's really i mean it
sounds like hell and
look and if you looked at our faces and
our attention
you'd think we were we were miserable
but this is this is what we love
this is our i understand it is uh it is
terrific and so
we'll know in advance uh six months that
there's that plan
and then peter and his team will start
working with individuals
who we've targeted and make a schedule
uh in general we'll do three people a
day sometimes if they're very long we'll
do two
occasionally if they're shorter we might
do four a day and these days are
14 16 hour days especially for the crews
it takes them
an hour and a half to to set up it takes
at least an hour to
to uh to break down the set
um and in between we probably have 10
12 10 hours of shoot of actual shooting
time
now what i do when i know those 15
individuals i'm going to have i will
have
you know at least a good solid two
months
of prior preparation where i will ask
each of the individuals with whom we're
interviewing to send me their papers
and i will go through those papers and
kind of structure it in my own mind how
we see the shows approximately because
everything
we want to get as much material in the
production as possible
and then later in the post-production we
decide what makes the best shows
uh but we have the raw material for our
actual interviews
and then prior to each interview i'll
send an outline of topics to the
individual
and say this is what we're talking not
specific questions but but rather here
are the topics we'll be dealing with
did i leave out anything something you
want to discuss that i haven't
mentioned um and we get that and then i
have that
that outline um and so i i have to go
into
each interview feeling uh
i i should put it this way fooling
myself to think i know
almost as much as that person does about
his
or her topic um and and if i have that
then
then the conversation is more natural um
and and that i i so i i prepare very
much for each of these interviews and
that's again a part of the fun for me is
really
learning and understanding and then
trying to relate
what how that person thinks and the
ideas to the big questions of closer to
truth
um because that's our core we have this
these big sets of uh big questions and
we
want to understand those questions which
a question
you know all humanity has um and we want
to understand that from diverse
perspectives
do you get people emailing you their
variegated theories of everything on
consciousness or physics
and how do you deal with that do you
welcome it for example
that's a very good question and uh
uh i i
really appreciate when uh people write
to us
in general i mean it's it's uh it's much
appreciated
i i read everything that comes in
directly
into phototruth.com and i
certainly skimmed through the large
majority of the comments on youtube
there are obviously so many now and and
i've tried to respond to
many of the ones that come in directly
and over time there have been
an increasing number of people who have
their own theories
um and i'm
you know polite uh in many
many times i you know i can't uh
accurately adjudicate some very
sophisticated aspect of uh of quantum
physics but
um you know the um
the the fact is is that if
if um there are examples in history
where people have made radical
breakthroughs
as we all know and the general
relativity and quantum theory but you
know it's not
it's not that uh frequent so many of the
ideas we get in uh in the physics area
and the consciousness
area are on the extreme
i i just i try to skim all of them
uh you know never knowing when something
and and even when
ideas are i wouldn't say crackpot i'd
say fringe or radical
it sometimes shows you a different kind
of way of thinking
um and and that to me is very helpful to
to understand
different ways of thinking sometimes
there are interesting insights that uh
that that people have uh but i can't
do you have an example of an interesting
insight off the top of your head
um yeah i i would say there's
one individual i don't want to mention
too many names who who has shown
with some rather bizarre
um comparisons between number theory and
quantum physics
but in his work showed the uh
high level of importance of chaos theory
in
understanding um deeper reality
for that chaos theory is more
fundamental than than it may seem on the
surface although it is
um and so that's an example the
mechanism by with which this individual
describes the
um some relations with number theory and
and quantum physics you know i i i don't
buy
and you know maybe i'm not qualified to
analyze but but as a result of
of going through it and seeing the
sophistication of thinking
uh it it it allows you to see
um uh perhaps see things that you
haven't
seen before so when anybody sends
something in i
i look at i look at everyone um i mean i
look at it for long
but i do look at everyone and and on
occasion i will uh comment um
there is a danger in commenting because
if you comment then you're gonna get
you know ten times as much back and then
now what do you do uh so right you know
the
the agencies of life require that i
can't
be in detailed communication with
dozens of people on sophisticated topics
i i just
can't you know i have to do some family
stuff
too for grandkids and whatever
so um it takes quite a bit of time to go
through
almost anyone's work in detail even if
it's non-academic and fluffy
it it may take an entire day yeah and
and
i i can't do that i think i've i've
gotten
uh over the years having done i don't
know
400 interviews and have read papers by
so many people in so many ways
at least in the areas that i'm familiar
with you know i'm not putting
[Music]
public policy health care in my list of
expertise
but in the areas that i have focused on
uh on closer to truth i am very very
familiar
with the scope of the field and in some
depth
and so i can pretty quickly scan a paper
in in our categories very quickly and
get a sense of
what what the the point is um and then
go
further uh as as it may be i've had two
um three experiences in the last year
where individuals
were presenting ideas that were um
that were not my traditional way of
thinking
uh and very sophisticated and i engage
with these people
and and consider them now colleagues so
out of the hundreds and hundreds uh
there are three and
maybe there'd be another one if i think
hard but
there are three and curiously uh maybe
not curiously all
three come present
from an eastern point of view uh two are
from india
uh and the third is from the netherlands
uh but he's presenting
about the concept of zero from an indian
point of view he's a
very sophisticated he's not a
professional philosopher but he's uh
he's as good as one and the two from
india one is a quantum physicist
who has very strong ideas about vedanta
the other is a an artist
uh in the tamil tamil tradition
uh who has written books on art and uh
um
and understanding art from a
philosophical point of view he was
trained as a computer scientist so he's
very knowledgeable about science he's an
artist and he has written these books
into
meal about art and understanding and
from each of these
i have uh engaged in serious
communication and have learned a good
deal
were there any interviews that you felt
particularly underprepared for
um i i would say my early interviews
uh with uh some some superstars i was uh
i don't know if i would say
underprepared i would say i
was i was uh nervous
and uh kind of awed uh by the
potential of of the experience i
can i can drop names but
people on the physics side stephen
weinberg
um frank wilcheck alan guth
uh andre lindy uh these are people who i
greatly respected and uh
many others in that category as well
just mentioning a few
um and intimidated uh by their work and
going in and wanting to
uh to do a good job on the philosophy
side um
richard swinburne alan alvin planing or
peter van impe
just to name a few very sophisticated
philosophers
i love philosophy i study philosophy but
i'm not a professional philosopher
nor my professional physicist obviously
and so these i have felt intimidated
going in but uh but
but in the process um uh
perhaps over prepared uh but still felt
intimidated and i got the
greatest compliment uh from one i won't
mention who said it but
one of the names i just mentioned told
me after
after uh uh the interview he said he
felt like he had gone through
a second set of phd prelims
which are when the professors ask you
these hard questions about all the
things that you do to
get you to the stage where you then do
your thesis so you do that you're
supposed to know the field
uh at that point so when he said that
that kind of uh that kind of made me
feel good
um but but but i i should tell you that
there's not a single interview that i do
that i don't feel apprehensive going in
because you never know enough
and you know i'm thinking with uh you
know several
several levels at the same time i want
to engage the individual
i really want to understand it
personally myself and then i want to
make sure our audience sort of gets it
too and it doesn't go over their head
and i
explain terms that are terms of art if i
if i need to do that in context so i
have to have this
kind of multi-uh level uh thinking
in each interview but it it never
changes in other words i don't feel so
confident going into an interview
that um i i i don't feel the
tension and the apprehension uh to
really
uh get it get it right um and and that's
that's a good thing
because uh um you know this is what i
love doing i love learning uh
i i genesis is closer to the truth is
that i want to learn this is not like i
know the answer i'm gonna tell people i
don't know
i wanna i wanna experience this and uh
and and and show my anxieties and
uncertainties along with everything else
so
you know one thing i i do want to
emphasize and and maybe now just a good
point
to describe it when many people write to
us
they say you know i really enjoy
watching closer to the truth
and the first thing and then they ask
whatever they want i said the first
thing i have to tell you
is that it's not closer to the truth
it is closer to truth and this is an
extremely important
distinction in fact when the show was
first named
um which i can tell you that story if
you're interested the
suggestion was it was in a um the
original name of the show
going back 20 years before 20 years was
called mine quest
and the subtitle was the closest you'll
get to truth
and uh the pbs president
at pbs station in orange county at that
time koce now pbs socal at that time mel
rogers
um said he didn't you know he's going to
give the show a shot
but he hated that title mine quest and
he said what is it about and i said the
subtitle was the closest you'll get to
truth
and he said that's it the closest you'll
get to the truth i said no no we can't
say
the truth take out the and and that's
the name close to the truth so
thanks to mel um uh who uh therefore
became the godfather of closer to truth
um
it it it is it is that so closer to
truth it's a
progressive and and when we write it we
we capitalize the two
to because we want to emphasize that
it's a process
and it's not the truth coming out at the
end
because we know the answer no it's a
process we all work through together by
getting some of the best thinking
um and uh testing one against the other
and and seeking diversity
we recognize we need diversity and in
today's world that's even more important
than which
we're striving to do that but in our
view the most important thing
is diversity of ideas and ideas that are
both sophisticated
and coherent
you can have a lot of diverse ideas that
are incoherent that's easy to do
and you know maybe we have to make that
judgment
but we love diversity in ideas and
that's what we have always strived to
do and now we're working to have more
diversity in
uh externalities as well okay
you use the word coherence now i'm
wondering do you subscribe to a
coherence
theory of truth or a correspondence or a
deflationary
and when you say closer to truth you
have to be
prioritizing one because they conflict
with one another and if what you're
saying is we put these intellectuals in
the ring and let them hammer it out
well then is it just social convention
which one
emerges as the consensus how are you
defining truth
okay so that's a very broad and
important question
and uh the the first way that i would
approach it is to divide
the ways of thinking about the word
truth uh
there is the the philosophy uh category
the correspondence theory uh the various
theories of
of truth you need truth makers to make a
truth
you know that this philosophical
uh approaches to it uh there's ways that
we use
uh truth in common usage and then
there's a way that we use
truth in in the common media today and
all of those kind of get
um kind of getting mixed up together
and so
that's one way to look another way to
look at it is you
you can't just define truth
without seeking the context for what
it is so many people will say argument
is truth reality truth is relative if
you're in one set of circumstances one
thing and if you're another set of
circumstances another thing
or if you have a different perspective
on life death
universe god whatever you'll have
different kinds of truths and they're
all
sort of um able to
exist together in some meta truth
dimensional
sense the way we look at
truth is that
we deal on closer to truth
with the kinds of questions
that should i can't say
absolutely does but i would feel
very strongly that there is
a truth to the questions we ask on
closer to truth the large majority in
cosmos consciousness for sure
and potentially on meaning as well and
i'd go out on a limb and say yes so when
all of the
topics that closer to truth deals with
there may be exceptions
that there really is an ultimate truth
that is singular and absolute
and non-relative now do i expect to ever
know that no
do i expect to make progress in
understanding
what those mean i think the answer is
yes because we're able to
ask the kinds of questions and see the
diversity of
of smart sophisticated coherent thinking
on these topics
even if they disagree radically on what
that answer
is on what that question is really
asking
so i would then take your question about
what is truth
and and limit it to how we deal with
truth on closer to truth
because we deal with the kinds of
questions that
should and i believe do have an ultimate
answer
even if it is not possible even not
possible in in principle
to get to that truth but the kinds of
truths that we
seek do have absolute answers
and those are the kinds of questions we
want to ask that have to do
with you know big big fundamental
questions
when you say absolute answers to me
that's still there's still quite a few
theories of truth that that could
qualify for so
perhaps tarsky's or a realist not an
anti-realist not a
pragmatic those are more relative but
then there's correspondence and
coherence
which could be seen as as subsets of uh
of an absolute truth so which one like
how so how do you know when you're
getting closer to the truth
or closer to truth if here's what i'm
wondering
one has an arrow and one wants to point
it to a bullseye but if one doesn't know
where the bullseye is
then how does one know if one is getting
closer and where to aim
uh i i i think you you know that by
the um it's almost
the difference between operant
conditioning and pavlovian conditioning
operant conditioning you're just
you're just selecting from the from the
universe of potential behaviors
and i think that's what we're doing we
we don't see the talk because if you see
the target as clearly as you
you've said as a as a bow and arrow to a
target
uh you then then you're imposing
on the nature of truth your own biases
and we're not doing that what we want to
do is use
a diversity of individuals uh who
we have we believe uh doesn't mean we've
got
everyone or we're perfect by any means
but
to bring diverse smart coherent thinking
to these kinds of
questions and to to broaden the the
uh the category of people that we work
with and again we're
wanting to do that with uh you know
eastern traditions and global philosophy
of religion uh we need to
broaden our uh our our universe
of people addressing those kinds of of
questions
but at the end of the day the questions
that we ask
i mean at its most uh a fundamental
level
in in um in cosmos is you know what are
what is the ultimate um bedrock
um uh uh undergirding
of uh of the physical world uh
is it quantum mechanics is it string
theory is it something
deeper below that you know what is it uh
in consciousness to ask a very
bimodal digital yes no
answer does consciousness require
anything beyond what we now call the
physical
physical explanation whether it's at the
neuronal level the synaptic level the
intracellular level or the or the
quantum level
all of that is physical does
consciousness
can consciousness be entirely explained
and we can discuss what that means
entirely explained in the physical world
that's a yes or no answer
does god as we've traditionally called
god
a um a being that created the universe
that is
whose existence uh is his essence and
all of those things however you define
the characteristics which we could also
talk about if you like
um does that
being uh existent exist
that's a yes or no answer now one of the
characteristics of it
is a different one but on those
questions so it doesn't really
matter is that is is the word god
correspond to a being who has those
characteristics
that that is a uh that is a
helpful approach to understand what you
are what you mean by truth i agree with
that
but at the end of the day the kinds of
questions we ask do have
a a a deep
absolute answer um which
or you're hoping it has a deep absolute
answer
no no i i i would just i would say there
is a deep answer
now i may not know it i may not even be
able to describe it
but however you you deal with those
questions does god exist or does
consciousness require
anything beyond the physical uh however
you define it
in some vague way whatever if that's
right then that's the ultimate truth
so there is an ultimate truth on how to
describe these questions
or how to give an answer to these
questions i do not hope to
achieve that i think i have come to
understand and i hope our viewers who
have
taken the journey with us during
these years that peter and i have
greatly enjoyed
appreciate these questions more than
they have i know i do
and i i thank you know the audiences
that made it possible and
foundations that have supported us as
well as my own little foundation
uh to give us that opportunity but uh um
the you know i call it we we
luxuriate in the questions and in that
process
uh get a feel for the kind of uh
of uh of ambiance that answers would
have
on either direction and so uh
you know if god exists or if god doesn't
exist is conscious if consciousness is
entirely physical
or if there's something beyond the
physical you know are there
alien intelligences in the universe uh
or no alien intelligences in the
universe whatever these
questions are that have answers we
believe that we have enriched the
understanding
not only of what the the importance of
the category
but also what it would mean if
either side of the answer were true so
we want to show what what either side is
one of the great uh
uh joys that i've had in closer to truth
is to see
um uh uh closer to truth being
recommended by both theist and atheistic
websites
and people saying you know they may do a
little bit on the other side but you
know there's some really good stuff
there
that's a great compliment especially
because both of those communities tend
to be
ardently against what they're not so if
you're an atheist you dislike
intensely when people talk about or
entertain theism
and vice versa how do you improve as an
interviewer
robert do you re-watch the episodes
obviously you do when you're editing are
you taking notes are you looking at your
mannerisms
are you thinking well what are you
thinking that's a great question
and and i think i have a personal
deficit
in not doing that um i don't like to do
that
um and part of the reason
it's not that i i'm you know upset that
i
make mistakes so in our raw interviews
uh peter and i you know leave in my
mistakes
uh because we want to make it organic uh
in the shows we'll make we have very
tight time so we we
are very specific on how we we edit in
order to tell a story
uh but in the raw interviews we let
everything in um i
i guess psychologically i like to look
to the future
um i don't um i don't like
dwelling uh and and seeing what i've
done in the past
and being happy about it or or
feeling pride or correcting it
i always want to look to the future so
if i you know on my mind right now
is the global philosophy of religion
because we have these 20 interviews
coming up over the next few months and
you know i'm starting to prepare and
learn about hinduism and
islam at a greater depth than i've known
before and i'm really looking forward to
that
um and similarly in philosophy of
biology uh
you know my background is from biology
my bachelors was in human biology from
johns hopkins
but um you know i'm i'm out of that
i'm not current in a lot of aspects of
biology so i've been
really learning about that and so um
the my uh
my capacity as an interviewer is
is related to my passion for the ideas
and my desire to learn
in preparation for the interview and to
learn during the interview so it's not
that i'm just asking get my list out
questions
i really want to engage with that person
and understand
how that person thinks about it and once
that's
done yeah i'm on to the next i don't
want to reflect back and you know i
should have asked this i should have
asked that um you know i mean there are
you know mannerisms sometimes i'm
looking
down on people and i don't mean to do
that and i need to be told
to do that peter's very good in his uh
directorial activity
he doesn't like my hair kind of nicely
combed he likes it
brushed up a little bit a little bit
messy to kind of reflect uh
kind of a kind of a scatter brained
intellectual approach to things as
opposed to
a more patted down look so i'm not sure
my hair is proper now
you mentioned that when you're in the
interviews you're trying to be as
engaged as you can be
and that's something that but at the
same time you have to wear different
hats because you're wondering about the
audience
maybe there are other factors that
you're weighing and that's something
that i struggle with as well
and for better or worse i err on the
side of
me being engaged and asking the
questions that i'm more interested in
regardless of if they use too much
jargon or technical depth even if some
audience members will find it extremely
simplistic or
overly complicated and
i imagine that limits the audience and i
could
monetarily benefit from a larger one and
then invest in it so that then later i
could go back to my previous style
but it's a balancing act and i'm
wondering what do you
weigh and how do you make that decision
so marketing is one
your engagement the answering of your
own questions is another
how do you navigate that that process
you know in one sense honestly i don't
try to navigate it i try to be
as engaged and pos as possible and have
the audience
come with us and many people say that
you know they don't understand a lot of
the
shows but they love watching it anyway
and we'll watch it over and over again
we have many many people like that and i
love that
about closer to truth in fact it's one
of the
one of the highlights of closer to truth
is to see the diversity
of people who are engaged and i i've
kind of come to my own theory about this
is that there are
there is this subset of humanity that
really are engaged with these big
questions
of consciousness life after death how
did the universe happen why is there
something rather than nothing is there a
god
all those kinds of questions and that no
externality by age
economic democrats race religion creed
national origin none of those factors
are
relevant i'm exaggerating maybe a little
bit to to
their engagement with with these
questions uh
the the best example that i can remember
was a viewer in the
early days of close to the truth a woman
who wrote in and said
you know i've uh i've only had a high
school education
uh but i love closer to chill love the
questions that you asked uh
and he said but i have my husband and i
have five sons
they think i'm nuts you know one's one
one drives a truck
and one is uh one and uh is a manager at
a warehouse
and they think their mother is
absolutely crazy to be interested and
watch
this this show this obscure show
and you said but recently my 13 year old
grandson
has engaged and has loved these
questions so
he and i my 13 year grandson and i
secretly watch closer to truth when my
husband and my sons and his father are
not around
uh and to me that's a wonder was a
wonderful story
because superficially you would never
say
that woman and that child were
closer to truth's demographic focus
and so that that to me is exciting
and so therefore i don't tr
we don't try to reach a demographic
um now as you get bigger people force
you to do that and so i'm not saying
repair but
the the original concept of closer to
truth is you know build it
and see who comes um i remember when
you know mel rogers and koce uh you know
more than 20
22 or so years ago now uh
said you know maybe we can we can run it
and i i you know i said to him even if
you run it at three in the morning and
it's
only on koce i'm excited to do this
because i it was the passion of the
ideas and the opportunity
and if people watch it and when they do
and now
you know we have terrific numbers all
over the world on
closer truth youtube and closer to
truth.com
um you know that that's a that's a um
a great satisfaction but the
satisfaction is not that oh yes we were
right no no the satisfaction is
that there are other people in the world
uh who
have gone through the same things that i
have
and have these same questions and we're
sharing it together
in in this global community that we're
all together and
it transcends all the externalities that
um
seem to divide us more so in today's
world
that uh the the kinds of questions that
we deal with and you deal with curt
simile are the questions that unite us
across all different
uh you know breaking all different
barriers i read each of the papers that
you sent me
the pdfs thank you for that one sentence
that
stood out to me i wrote down it's simple
sentence it says to me honestly nothing
makes sense
so then that has me thinking
well
well one
when you said that there's absolute
truth and i'm not
critiquing absolute truth but to me that
presumes classical logic
it either is true or it isn't and then
there are various forms of classical
logic so how are you
sorry there's not various forms of
classical logic there are various forms
of logic intuitionist para consistent
and so on
so then why did you arrive at that and
then also well
what is it that you believe aft if
nothing makes sense that's something
that i struggle with
i'm also wondering how is it that you
avoid this nihilistic
trap of of psychologically
home being homeless or philosophically
being homeless i'll
make those questions succinct so number
one you're using a a form of logic
why did you choose that one uh okay um
let me let me uh go back to the to the
the last one because structure
because i i as i said i looked
juried in the questions um and when i
said
nothing makes sense that that was not
you know
about everything in the world i mean i
mean turn on the faucet the water comes
out that makes sense
yeah unless you scrutinize it then you
realize
but th this was specifically about you
know
what is existence and uh you know why
what what is existence so you can have
one theory that you know
god is uh is a a a necessary being and
god created the universe
that's one theory another theory is that
the laws
the deep laws of physics whatever they
are
are cosmogenic um pick your
choice there are lots of different ones
and all i'm saying is of
all those different categories none of
them make sense
and obviously one is true
and you know that's that's where where
where i start now
if when you get into the the classical
bimodal logic or the
um the tetralemma logic of
of eastern traditions um you know i
can't tell you i'm an expert in the
difference
in in how the tetralemma uh argument of
of uh was it you know p or minus p
both both both plus v and minus v
and minus playing you know each of those
uh i i i think
my senses is that those terms are in
that form of logic is being used in a
um in in in a in a blurry
way and that um you know
at the end of the day the kinds of
questions that we ask
have a a a digital yes no
kind of answer once you define
what that ult what that choice is
take the question is conscious does
consciousness demand
anything beyond the purely physical
world
now you can you can blur that question
by say well what do you mean by
physical and if you have a fifth force
of nature or a pan psychist point of
view or
you know does that count as physical or
not physical
or how do you how do you work that out
well that's that's a semantical point
about what you deal but ultimately if
that's the answer
then that answer is becomes an absolute
answer however you
create that answer even in a fuzzy
manner
so um to
to deal with the question
as i said does god exist or traditional
god or is there
is consciousness demand anything beyond
the physical
um you know what what does it mean what
would it mean
to have a uh a non-bimodal logic
to those questions so if consciousness
is uh physical
it requires something beyond the
physical
um if that's
either does or doesn't but if you have a
four-fold logic it would it would say
that
it it it um uh it doesn't dozens at the
same time
or it doesn't and does doesn't doesn't
and both are wrong
um and and that can give you an insight
into the complexity of these questions
but ultimately there
is there has to be some kind of an
answer they can't
you you can't if if
if we're defining the physical world and
again you can you can expand your
thinking of what the physical world is
that's another set of issues but if you
restrict it to the physical world and
his consciousness
demanding more of that what would it
mean
to say there's a to use the other two
forms of logic
to that question that means it does and
doesn't at the same time
it it it does require something
non-physical
and doesn't require non-physical and
both are true
if that's the case if that's the case
it's hard to conceive but if that's the
case
if does and doesn't at the same time
the fact that it does i think would
would skew the answer to that it it does
because
it's kind of a possible world analysis
uh this is a technique in philosophy you
may be familiar with in it
it asks what happens in in every
possible world now possible world is it
an
entire state of affairs so it's not just
a world like a planet or something it's
it's the
it's all reality and a different
possible world could be you know if
there are 10 to the 90th
particles in the universe if one
particle is in a slightly different um
polarization that's a separate world
everything else could be the same so
there's an
infinite number of possible worlds so
you ask questions
is something possible
is to ask is in any possible world can
that exist
now there's the the this has been used
in what's called the ontological
argument for god's existence
which basically says you know if you can
conceive of a god that is uh
maximally everything uh you know
totally omni uh or omnipresent or
everywhere omnipotent omniscient uh um
if you can all of those things the
maximum possible guard that which there
cannot be anything greater
um could that you don't know where that
god exists but could that
go could that kind of god exist in one
possible world yeah maybe i could
maybe maybe i'd see in a zillion
infinite number of possible worlds maybe
one of them that kind of god could exist
so when you when you admit that and then
you go into that possible world
in that possible world god is all
uh a god it is a necessary being so if
god's
unnecessary being in that one world then
it has to be if it's a necessary being
god has to exist
and so you've gotten into a logical trap
uh
i don't believe the ontological argument
proves god's existence
but very smart philosophers have
difficulty finding out the
the error in the in the argument that i
just made which is the called the modal
ontological argument for god's existence
uh it doesn't work for sure
i mean i don't believe that but it is a
tricky argument so now what that does
is it goes back to the questions we're
asking in a four-fold logic system
if you have a consciousness being
something that
uh is both um
fully explained by the physical world
and
not fully explained by the physical
world which contradicts
our twofold logic classical logic that
would seem to indicate
even with that four-fold logic that in
one of those
one possible world consciousness uh
does require something beyond the
physical
and therefore it it would indicate that
it
that if it is true in one possible world
that it is
then that it is a true a truism
even though it may not be in the vast
majority of of worlds
um so i mean that's an argument
that i i would i would at least uh
suggest
that shows that a the four-fold logic
is helpful in in
being able to see deeply into some of
these very hard questions
and i need to learn more about about
that and and
uh and i look forward to to doing that
and when we're dealing with
global philosophy of religion and
eastern traditions and the big questions
of these two big series coming up
um we'll we'll explore that um
and i think those that that complexity
of logic
enables a deeper understanding of what
these questions mean
uh but i'm still you know backward
enough or west
too westernized to to think that at the
end of the day
uh it uh it it it is going to alter my
thinking about
the the the uh the fact that there is an
answer to these questions within a
twofold logic classical system
system okay let's harp on this for a bit
with the twofold logical system you said
it's obvious it's either yes or no and
then you gave a case where it's
imagine consciousness both is physical
and not physical but you can
develop a logical system where it's not
true that consciousness
is physical but it is true that
consciousness is physical and
not physical if you put the bracket
behind both true and not true
but not true in the singular for the
consciousness
and then you said well it's obviously
true but
i don't i don't necessarily see it as
being obvious because
well firstly as a scientist your whole
point is to question what's obvious
so dispense with the word obvious when
you're a scientist
and number two if you've been emailed
several theories about
zero or you're going to be interviewing
indian philosophers about zero
often they have this notion that zero is
the same as infinity and thus it's the
same as all possible worlds
and thus you can see how it can be true
and not true at the same time so i don't
see it obviously being
the case or not the case only
yeah um and so and so as i think that i
think
what we're doing is enriching the
understanding of aspects of of reality
and
and that's fine and i look to be able to
uh
to appreciate that better um but
i i don't think you're going to shake me
off my uh
my view that at the end of the day there
is
there is some description of reality
in each of these categories that is the
the the correct and the one that
corresponds to
to the reality it can be much more
sophisticated or complex
than i would think now and you're
describing ways maybe that's
the case but if that is the case then
that is the
that is how to define it you also
you mentioned in one of your articles or
many of your articles that you dislike
faith
now do you see anything i i i
that that's a probably an um slightly
mischaracterization
it's not that i dislike it um
maybe i like it it's just that i don't
have it
okay okay so you don't have faith do you
see any
aspects of faith in the answer that you
can't be shaken from your
beliefs about whether or not
there's one answer to a question yes or
no
once again when i'm saying there's one
answer to it i'm not saying that i know
what each side of those answers are now
uh i am saying that when we define
the um the structure of of the
of the answer there is one way to define
that structure
even if parts of it have uncertainty or
however
you want to to deal with it however you
you define that
there is ultimately an answer to those
those questions
it is that you can that you can
phrase um you know the issue of faith
is in a different kind of category um
uh you know faith is is a belief in
something the evidence may be of which
you don't see
um and in various religions
uh that is a virtue and i i see it as a
virtue
and i admire people who have it that
doesn't mean i think it's either correct
or that i
uh want it maybe i would want it but i i
don't have it the way
many people have faith um
when i'm talking about uh my
belief that there are ultimate answers
to these questions even if we can never
even define what that is
uh i i don't think that that's a a a
i wouldn't characterize that as faith
although
it's it's it is part of my belief system
um
and you know happy to question it
i'm not coming at this from a theist's
point of view or an atheist's point of
view
i'm just playing devil's advocate when
it comes to faith
i hear people say many times that they
don't like belief
they don't like faith no i'm not saying
you didn't you said this and i apologize
if i misquoted you
but when people say faith faith is
actually
manifold they're i think on the
stanford encyclopedia there's
there's doxastic venture non-doxastic
venture special knowledge hope
belief affective confidence
trust and sure then when someone says
they don't have faith well
do you not have trust do you never have
confidence and then when someone says
well i only trust what i have evidence
for yeah but you're presuming
what evidence counts as so let's say
someone from the eastern tradition would
prioritize experiential knowledge
but then you not saying you sorry i'm
saying one may
prioritize scientific verification
okay but you've just slipped the
question because you've just
i've asked you do you have faith you say
only believe what i have evidence for
well what counts as the evidence and
then you have a an assumption there as
to what
is accurate evidence so what do you say
to that
yeah look i think those are all very
legitimate questions we've been dealing
with that on closer to truth because a
lot of people
will ask us to interview x y and z
person who
are people of uh of spirituality
in various traditions many of them are
from eastern traditions but also in
christian judeo-christians who are
messengers of uh of uh experiential
uh truths um and we're
we're not saying we reject that we're
saying that that's just not part of the
way we
we we address these questions but
recognize that those are
answered that those are approaches that
many people feel are not only
legitimate but are more legitimate than
the quasi-analytic scientific approach
that we have
i i distinguish by the way between
scientific
method and the scientific way of
thinking
and i do not believe that
all truths of significant nature are
accessible by the scientific method
which is
experiments or observation repeatability
testing etc
i do not think many of the questions are
susceptible to that because
science the scientific method has a
physicalism
um foundation and so anything outside of
physicalism
would not be subject to the scientific
method
by definition so none of these questions
can really get at if there is something
beyond
the physical world through a scientific
method however
that does not free you from
a scientific way of thinking and a
scientific way of thinking
has to have a logic
built into it and has to have knowledge
of the sea of the sequence of the flows
of your argument
and i am i try to be very rigorous
about putting people to that test uh
this particularly
would be in philosophy of religion to
theists and even
atheists um and forcing people if they
want to take me
to a belief in god or belief in
cosmic consciousness or idealism or
something
um i i want to see the progression of
steps
that goes from what what we all know
with third-party verification
that we all can agree upon and to their
conclusion
and in virtually every case there will
be gaps
in the logical flow because you can't go
from a scientific
method of understanding the world to
getting something
outside of of what the scientific method
can access you can't do that it's just
such a self self contradictory and so
all i want to do
is to point out where those gaps are
and how those gaps are are are bridged
it and and that that's a very fair
and legitimate and coherent kind of
analysis
is to go uh from what we all can agree
upon
to questions about the existence of god
or the nature of consciousness um
or life after death or whatever um as a
as a belief but i want to see when
you're making those
those jumps over that you're that you're
leaping over
a uh a logical flow
um and and then we point those
areas out and you're entirely uh
um justified
in making those jumps but i just want to
be sure that we're all aware that they
are because many times people make those
jumps and not aware of it
and that to me is not acceptable so
you and if you want to use faith or you
know the inner experience that you've
had with the
you know with your religious belief
that's fine i just want to know where in
the sequence of steps that's occurring
and then we we really have a deep
understanding
of what that that process is and if you
want to call that faith during that time
fine but i want to see where that's
occurring
so then we're all on the same sort of
logical
flow logical timeline together but
by seeming to be so you know scientific
way of thinking or analytic philosophy i
want to be clear that i do not reject
at all the those who
use other ways of knowing experiential
religious um as coming to what may be
true i don't i do not reject it i just
want to be very clear
where those gaps are being uh uh
leaped uh left uh and
and the um and to acknowledge those
and to you know call that faith or call
that whatever but just to see
the sequence of thinking from you know
what we can all agree upon
to what your conclusion is which we may
not agree upon
you know how you're how you're going
through that process that's that's what
we try to do and if we can all
all do that together i i think we will
we will have better communications
does science or the scientific method
presume physicalism or give evidence for
physicalism
i i think this the scientific method
which is the
uh the way science works is
uh is the core
way that you understand the physical
world
and the the two are inextricably bound
together
science is the use of the scientific
method
to understand the physical world um
and the the physical world is the uh
is the substrate by which the scientific
method works
um and you can't go
beyond that you should not go beyond
that the only thing i
began to repeat is that i i generalize
it
from scientific methods to scientific
way of thinking
in order to get beyond the physical
world if there is such a thing beyond
the physical world
um in whatever sense consciousness guide
whatever spiritual stuff
if there is um to use a scientific way
of thinking because you surely cannot
use a a scientific method uh
to to get there so i i
would be very suspect of people who try
to use a scientific method to
prove things beyond the physical world i
think that's
that's contradictory well i know that
you have a scheduled interview for
bernardo castro
i maybe it's unconfirmed but you're in
talks with him
and he makes an extreme
extremely cogent argument that the
scientific method presumes no philosophy
doesn't presume materialism physicalism
or idealism and what's happened was
a grave error where we think we have
initially these
pixels of perception i'm seeing you
right now and you see a
you see paintings well you can't see the
paintings behind you if you were to look
you would see the paintings behind you
and then we see regularities in our
perception
our perceptive field so we start with
these mental states then we see
perceptive
regularities and then we start to make
models about them and then at some point
we assume
that this exists as an entity in and of
itself
and that posits a completely new
ontological category
when one if one is to take scientific
modeling
seriously it uses a principle called
parsimony so you want the minimal amount
of assumptions
and i i don't see a flaw with this
argument that the minimal amount of
assumptions would lead you naturally to
idealism
now i'm not saying i believe in idealism
i'm saying that i don't see how one can
hold both parsimony
and physicalism or at least parsimony
and not idealism
well parsimony is a is a principle i
mean einstein
you know he has a lot of quotes i assume
this is accurate but he
said make things as simple as simple as
possible but not
simpler so you know general relativity
to some people is extremely simple these
elegant equations and
others it's uh you know it's
incomprehensible um
and so parsimony is
is great but doesn't always
work i mean the orbits of the planets
peak
philosophers and you know quasi
scientists in
antiquity you know assumed that there
were some
wheels within wheels and then some
platonic structures that had all the
orbits and
the orbits are just not that way they're
all
based upon some basic principles but
they're all have their own
characteristics
so you know simplistic and and and
parsimony
is a very good principle but it is not
it is not
a certainty to access
reality um yeah i understand all those
arguments uh
you know i uh bernardo and and we uh
we're trying to get together we have
closer truth has a difficult um
uh schedule because of our as i told you
the productions are very
very significant but um you know next
year we hope to be we
plan to be we will be in the uk and uh
bernardo will be on so we will deal with
these things in great detail and uh look
forward to it
um but uh the kinds of arguments that
that uh you're posing you know lead very
quickly to
you know total skepticism and you know
that i can make that argument
as well because it's it's the brain and
the vat i mean anything i'm perceiving
and i'm perceiving
you know through my brain that's why i
originally wanted to
do my phd in brain science rather than
physics or philosophy or other things i
was thinking about because
i had the thought that everything comes
through your brain and so if
we understand the brain we can have a
better sense of
of reality because that's our only way
of perception so we're never going to
get around that i mean that's
that's obvious and so from that you can
have all sorts of
different derivations of you know
anti-realism
is is an easy argument to make because
you don't really have access to any
underlying reality in a
in a uh in a direct sense it all has to
be mediated by
some sensations uh that that we all have
and those are
subject to all sorts of uh
all sorts of problems and issues that
that we
are not aware of in our daily life but
in all different kinds of trauma
diseases they become very obvious
and so any of those arguments are
you know are cannot be totally refuted
because at the end of the day
anything we know is coming from our is
translated into
nervous impulses through eyes and and
hearing
other senses um so
you know i like those arguments i enjoy
them we can discuss them
but if you take them
too seriously i mean it really ends the
conversation
well with bernardo there's nothing that
he says that
violates any scientific theory in the
least because
you could just take the regularities
that we see in nature as the physical
law
and then you mentioned well simple but
not any simpler okay why because at some
point it won't work
and then my question is well what
doesn't work about
idealism and
furthermore sorry what so you mentioned
simpler but not simple but not simpler
okay why not simpler
the reason is because at some point it
won't work any longer the orbits are
are oblong or elliptical right okay
okay that means that there's a breakdown
of the theory okay from what we can
tell what's wrong about idealism
no i'm saying what's wrong with idealism
and also can physicalism be refuted and
then if physicalism nor idealism can be
refuted then the belief in one or the
other to me
seems like a faithful step which you've
assumed
i think that's right we have had several
shows on closer to truth where we asked
the question
is the universe theologically ambiguous
and uh all the people we we speak to
don't like that question because to each
one of them the answer is it's not
ambiguous
and obviously the theists think it's not
ambiguous because god does exist and the
atheists think it's it is
it is not ambiguous but nobody liked the
idea that it was ambiguous i like the
idea that it's ambiguous
nobody else i talked to really liked it
i'm exaggerating but making the point
um what does it mean what do you say the
universe is ambiguous just for the
audience who
is like what the heck is that possibly
theologically ambiguous meaning
that can data support both the existence
of god
and the and the absence of god
and the answer to me is yes and the
to me this is not a a hard question
because you know i have a lot of very
very very smart
friends and colleagues and many we've
interviewing closer to truth on both
sides of that question
and you know i'm not prepared to say one
of those groups are
you know really missing some very
specific uh
kind of data um and i expect when we get
into global philosophy of religion and
reach out to
you know hindu and islamic traditions
and greater depth than we ever had and
uh
and buddhism that we'll find equally
strong
views i know we will of course that's
why we're doing it
so um i take the view that the data from
the
universe the data that's fed into our
uh ways of apprehension both directly in
ourselves
and through our scientific process over
the last
four five centuries as science says has
developed has
um has amplified both sides of the
argument
um and so both both uh um
theists and atheists have been um
have seen the results of science
corroborating
their fundamental ideas about how
how things work so people impose their
way of thinking on data
but the data itself has to have some
ambiguity
about it or else that wouldn't be
possible to happen now
the the the the physicalists would say
that's because the other side is
imposing their
artificial experiential selves onto
data and and and kind of skewing it
and and the theatres may say that as
well that
they are imposing their that they
believe in god that this
inner experience they've had is is both
meaningful
and uh um certain in their minds
uh but the raw data of the universe
can be interpreted in in in various ways
you know i've used uh this different
ways of interpretation
uh to um to illustrate
uh or illustrate that by taking a a
question
um are there alien intelligences that
are sentient in the way that
human beings are sentient maybe very
different but are there
and i i pose i i pose it as a two-fold
matrix
in terms of of uh are there aliens
such as sentient aliens or not so that's
a that's
that's one one axis the other axis is
are you a theist or are you an atheist
and i want to fill in all four of those
boxes
so if you're a uh a theist
and the universe is uh is teeming with
life
you say you know see god made a universe
that had all this alien life and if
you're an atheist then you see the
universe teeming with life
you say see god didn't do anything
special about earth earth are just an
ordinary
part and have gazillions of of of
sentient life in the universe so
so you know atheism is clearly right now
if there are
no other sentient life in the universe
the theists will say see we earthlings
and
human beings on earth are a special
creation of god
and therefore god exists the atheists
will say see
this the universe is wholly inhospitable
to life
and it's only on this random planet that
one thing had occurred so that god
can't possibly exist so here you take a
very simple
case of whether they are sent in aliens
or not and interpret it
from both the theist and atheist point
of view and neither will change their
fundamental position no matter what the
answer is
now if that's the case if you give me
that then any of these other questions
will fall in the same category and as i
idealism versus physicalism versus
panzerkiss
and so we can do our best to really
understand the nature of each of the
argument
to give us a richer understanding of the
questions
but um you know i have no uh
no uh not just no no belief no hope
that there'll be an ultimate answer
because i think that's
that is given the circumstances we have
that
it's probably in principle impossible
you and i think so much alike robert
when it comes to sitting on on the fence
for many issues and citing
well how can you be so confident about
your answer given that there are people
who are extremely bright on both sides
and sometimes when i see i'm pretty sure
you get the same feeling when you look
at the comments
most of the time they're extremely
positive and and sitting with ambiguity
but plenty of the time you'll see people
say these people are obviously incorrect
because
god for sure exists or god for sure
doesn't exist i heard someone recently
say religion lowers your iq
come on why do you think that
what makes you think that someone else
why do you think the other side says
what they do do you think it's because
they're
unconsciously motivated by something
malicious well
we all are to some degree but do you but
more than you and do you think that it's
because they have a paucity of the data
that you have access to
there's a great quote called there's a
great quote by kane i believe
that that in in great controversy
not one side is mere folly or only the
shallowest of mine would think that in
great controversy one side is mere folly
i tend to subscribe to that and you seem
to be doing the same as well
that's my favorite my favorite uh
critique
yeah i know it's great that's great and
my favorite critique was in one show
must have been something to do with god
within about
five or ten comments
on youtube one person said yeah it was
good uh
but cune is is is too much a promoter of
theism from my taste
and then ten comments later it was yeah
it was a
show i learned a lot but you know he's
an atheist
and uh you know he doesn't believe in
god and you know i'm not i'm not going
to really pay attention
so it was i mean normally it's a
different place but he was in the same
context in the same show some people
accuse me of being an atheist and some
people accuse
being a theist in a in a negative manner
for both
a critical matter and i took that as a
compliment by the way you used a phrase
i don't agree with i
agree with everything you said except
one thing i don't think i'm sitting on
the fence
and i don't think you are either it's
not a sitting on the fence
it's a very sharp-eyed uh tough-minded
approach to the to to to to questions
now i could be wrong and when i'm wrong
i'd love to be wrong because then i
learn
uh but i i um i think of what i want to
do
is being very tough-minded very very
critical thinking
and and being able to and and being
open-minded
in a very real sense at the same time
and being hopeful i always i
often say that you know i i fear my hope
is swamping my reason um and so i'm
trying to be careful about that when i
when i think
but it's not sitting on the fence uh it
you know i take these questions very
seriously i have my whole life the great
opportunity to
discuss with many people i'm joined
discussing with you today kurt
um and these are questions which you
know all human beings face
at the same level and i think that's the
important thing in today's world too
that we
we all share these these ways of
thinking um
which which uh you know can go a long
way towards
bridging uh ostensible gaps between
people
i'm going to match your agreement slash
disagreement with another disagreement
slash agreement
so i would say yes i agree i'm not
sitting on the fence in the traditional
sense of
being on it well i am in the sense that
i'm unable to make up my mind
because as soon as i posit one position
i can almost
immediately see a counter to that
position and it's difficult for
in my mind it's just even when i'm
writing i just see flaws flaws flaws
flaws with almost each side
so that's what i mean when i say on the
fence and then as for
as for you saying that you like to be
wrong i don't think so robert
and i'll tell you why you don't want to
be wrong about your wife not loving you
or wrong about reason leading you
reason not leading you to truth because
your whole show is based upon reason and
argumentation leading to some place
that's closer to truth so i want to say
globally
you care you're excited to be wrong
unless
please tell me if i'm wrong about that
on specific
topics uh if i if i think a certain way
and then i find out that's not correct
in some sense uh you know that to me is
a learning experience i
i i like that i mean i i've had uh
from uh um comments of you know
a greater appreciation i've thought
harder
about experiential even though we still
don't deal with that on closer to truth
because i have no way of adjudicating um
you know which you know the wheat from
the chaff and the huge amount
in that area that's just not what we can
do but i
do appreciate that that is a
consideration
that needs to be um admitted and
we we we do that on closer to truth but
but we don't then
explore that further by testing all
different
uh different uh you know experiential
claims uh that various teachers or gurus
or
ministers or whomever um that's that's
not what we would do
um so but my thinking on that for
example has been
expanded a little bit um and
uh we've talked before about logic and
i've
would have thought that the classical
logic is is is the only way the laws
have excluded middle and
all of that um but the
there because a different logical system
particularly you know the eastern uh
tetralem i think that's what it's called
the four the four kinds of logic it
gives you a deeper insight
into into ways of thinking about deep
questions so um that's
that's a learning experience um now how
that
affects anyone needs to consider
when when i say i like being wrong it's
i i'm not saying that in a global sense
that you know i'm i'm
uh i i miss my calling and i
i i should have believed in god or
should never have dealt with questions
about god no i don't i don't think i'm
wrong about that
uh but whenever there's something that
uh you know that i learned that was
different i mean i look upon that as
as progress well robert the reason i
bring that up
is because i'm sure you see this too i'm
constantly
almost unconsciously assessing people of
their unconscious motivations
and when i hear people say i'm sure you
see this too when they say well i love
to be wrong richard dawkins has a story
about this
i want i wonder how much of that is
marketing or
trying to show one's rational
intellectual
proclivity by saying well look i'm not
guided
i'm not the catholic church where i say
kneel down and obey and listen to
whatever
i actually follow the data wherever it
may lead me well first of all
i don't buy that i don't think that's
necessarily true if the data led you to
kill yourself or led you to kill
destroy the world would you do so
and then if it does well maybe you
should question your own reasoning and
also when people say they don't like
faith or they don't have faith or they
don't have beliefs
well i see that also as pounding their
chest
or at least pounding their brain in an
analogous chest thumping manner
by saying look how
scientifically rational intellectual i
am and something i think intellectuals
dislike more
than appearing to then being irrational
is appearing to be irrational
i'm questioning when people say for
example you mentioned you don't have
faith
well do you drive your car and then you
may say yes i drive my car
okay do you have faith you're not going
to get into an accident well my faith is
based on evidence
okay but but okay
i know i'm speaking for you here sorry
let me ask you
you say that you don't have faith do you
drive a car
no but you're interpreting faith in a
much broader term what i'm saying faith
is is faith in in in willing to
give um uh to allow
kind of an inner feeling of wanting
there to be a god
uh and allow that to um become
your dominant belief system i you know
for better works i would like there to
be
a god in the traditional sense that
would
i think be pretty pretty cool about the
way the world works and
and what the potential of human beings
are in terms of life after death or
whatever
but i i'm not i don't have the faith to
make that leap between
that hope and the belief so i don't have
the belief
and i would like to because i don't have
the faith to do that
uh you're using the word faith in my
broader term and
that's not the way i when i say i don't
have faith i mean
faith in that very specific thing to
make the leap from what i
know about the the the world and
philosophical analysis and everything to
an absolute belief
in in god i think i'm using that term in
a very
limited sense to that we
all have predispositions in our belief
system everybody has belief
a belief system that's founded on on
principles
uh some of which are obvious to us and
many of which are not uh
you know scientists who say that you
know
philosophy is dead or there is no
room for philosophy it's distorting you
know
they are practicing philosophy they are
giving a philosophy when they say that
when i say philosophy is dead there's no
that is a philosophy that is a
a philosophy you may think it's amateur
philosophy or bad philosophy but it is a
philosophy
and so you know when i use the word
faith i'd use it in in that
context but if we want to broaden the
concept to
how we deal with various ways of dealing
with the world or with truth
you know what we're i i would i would i
would offer a different way of thinking
about it rather than using the term
faith i'd use the term belief system
so we all have a belief system
which uh which operates in the
background for whatever we're doing if
we're driving a car we have a belief
system about that
if we're thinking about the nature of
consciousness or god or
life after death we have a belief system
that we bring
to that discussion so i think
human belief systems is a wonderful
topic
for deep explanation and that is a
closer-to-truth
theme we we deal with belief systems and
how belief systems come about
uh both in all respects although we have
maybe a
a skewed towards religious belief
systems and how they come about
but these are fascinating conversations
so we had one television show you know
religion without god you know what is
what does that mean how does that
develop
uh that's interesting yeah so
so belief systems is is an exciting
way of thinking about it and i would put
the way i would define
faith as a small subset of the broader
topic of belief systems
okay help me out robert so there are
belief systems about
operating a computer or a vehicle and
and then there are belief systems about
faith in god and so on now what's the
difference
between one why is it okay well
why is it rational to have a belief
system about driving a car
and being confident about one's
abilities to drive a car versus
irrational to have faith in uh
a deity let's say or multiple deities
or whatever other religions espouse
i'm trying to find out what's the
difference between those
well i think it in the ultimate sense
there is no difference
in terms of belief systems being
a mechanism by which human mentality
uh deals with
sentience and it's in its world so we
deal with our worlds
through our belief systems belief
systems are
uh inculcated by uh by your own personal
experience
and they're they're they're inculcated
by
the culture from which we live i mean
one argument against religion and that's
a strong one
is that if you go to
the western world you know christianity
is 90 percent or whatever and you go to
india and hinduism is whatever the
president is 70
and islam is 30 whatev whatever the
numbers are
um and you know did all these people
make those decisions on
in a rational sense of course that's
impossible
uh if if that would occur you'd have a
the entire world
sort of in every country having a
similar
kind of percentage of people making
their decisions so
we have a tremendous amount of uh
of our our whole lives are built upon
belief systems i had an experience that
it may sound trivial but it was really
very meaningful to me my first
granddaughter when she was
when she was learning to walk she had a
toy that was a walker
and she just was starting to walk and
and she was wanted to get to the other
side of the room and she kept pushing
into a
hammock or a chair and she couldn't
because she couldn't get
through the chair she kept pushing she
wanted to get to the other side she
couldn't get through the chair
okay and then she slipped and she slid
and
she got around the chair and it was one
trial learning the next time she came
there she knew she just went around the
chair
and so when she first saw that
she want to get to the other side of the
room you just go straight
because that's the belief system when
you go straight you get there quicker
it doesn't matter if there's a chair in
the way you just go and but she couldn't
and then then the next thing she learned
was that
if there are things in the way if you go
around them
even though it's longer it's longer to
go around and to go through
but as you do that you can get you it
works
so that that was an example that i saw
literally
right there where a belief system
was being developed it was a belief
system with how to deal
with things in the world now that's very
simplistic
but i think if that analogy and that and
that mechanism
applies to lots of you know gets much
more
complicated and and and and filters
everything that we have
and so one challenge for us when we're
dealing with these very big questions
of existence of god or nature of
consciousness life after death or
whatever
is to is to challenge our own belief
systems and to
see what are the assumptions that our
belief systems are making
and uh in in doing this i think we see
broader opportunities and and
broader ways of thinking and how other
smart people think and that's what we
try to do
on on closer to truth we try to
understand how presuppositions we don't
always call it belief systems but how
presuppositions and ways of thinking
lead to certain kinds of conclusions and
what the how different people make
different arguments to get there
but they're all based upon these uh uh
perhaps um unconscious uh kinds of
modules that are parts of our belief
system i think
and that's a good way to think about it
our belief system have these modules and
the
marvin minsky talked about a society of
minds and
in his classic book um and so we have
these modules
mental modules that we've had many of
which are unconscious
and to deal with these big questions i
like to uncover what these
what these mental modules are which are
our fundamental assumptions
and then allow people to come to their
conclusions but to see the
logical process uh that they go through
this
analogy or this story with the your
granddaughter
is it your friend okay your
granddaughter going from point a to b
see to me this means that there's a
pragmatic definition of truth
embedded within what you said because
the first model is let's go to a and b
in a b line
and then the second and that fails and
then the second is let's go around it
and then you validate the model based on
the goal based on if it gets you the
goal which is a pragmatic theory of
truth
and before you were and pragmatic
theories of truth are somewhat relative
so to me that goes against what you
earlier said what you said earlier about
there being an absolute yes or no yeah
but
but what i think i think we're we're
we're using truth just like we use faith
in different ways truth is
an english word five letters and as
meaning when you bring it but uh they're
very very different kinds of
of truth certainly there are pragmatic
truths and and
and they they can be very volatile i
mean
you know morality is it absolute or
relative and there's a you know
huge literature and a constant battle
about
about
those kinds of things when i'm using
the word truth and as we use it on
closer to truth the scope
of what we're talking about as truth is
extremely limited if you look at
all the questions of of human life and
existence and sentience
the kinds of truth that we're focusing
on on closer to truth
are a miniscule subset of all the kinds
of truths that there could be
and so when i'm using the term truth
that there is an absolute truth answer
to the kinds of questions we ask even
though we'll never get
to it enough i'm not here to tell you
what those answers are that's for sure
um that that that's a different
category so i will defend the notion
that there is an
absolute truth about these big questions
even though we won't
know that we wouldn't even know what it
means
that that that we would know that i mean
we don't we wouldn't even know what a
verification
how verification uh could be
um for for example um one of our
our uh contributors uh contributed less
well-known but very sophisticated sadly
he died
bead rundle uh from oxford who's a
very strong atheist uh he said this he
said
if i were trying to be convinced to be a
theist which he was not
um and i went to a you know a shrine or
or holy waters and i saw
a person who believed in god suddenly
materialized two limbs that they didn't
have they had no arms and suddenly they
had arms
uh and that person said therefore god
exists
i mean suddenly and i saw that myself
and i was sure it happened
he said i would think it more likely
that it was an
alien ship on the dark side of the moon
beaming special healing rays to that
lady
then there is a god
and to me that you know that sounds
ridiculous in its sense but you think
about it that's
really profound because to this person
the existence of a god in the
traditional way is so
um is so unlikely
that even an extreme explanation that he
had
to explain a certain set of data
whereas everybody else you know could if
they saw that which nobody has by the
way
and certainly in recent times even no
claims to that
um they would they would
look upon that it's just a you know a
god-driven miracle
what was that person's name
what was the person
his first name is b rundle you can look
yeah you can search him on closer to
truth.com have interviews with him
he wrote a very interesting book called
why there is something rather than
nothing
uh which uh gives one answer to that big
question that you know i'd like to
to deal with uh that's one of his his
his works but he's a very strong atheist
and a very good thinker
well i find beat rundle's argument
except that i agree with it yeah
facetious
unless he was being purposefully so or
specious at least because
firstly it depends on how one defines
god and their interdictions against that
in virtually every religion
especially the judeo-christian and
islamic tradition second
it so what definition of probability are
you using to say that this probably
isn't the case
there's a measure theoretic definition
that's the mathematical one
what what what is it what he was
illustrating not facetiously he was
illustrating
that that we're so used to definitions
of god
that we think it it it it is logical
it it it is a uh it is a definition
that that is
acceptable within the range of
probabilities and what he what he's
saying
he was just using it to show from his
perspective on a on a de novo
basis uh just looking at a thing
probably that the existence of such a
being
is so extraordinarily um uh
unlikely and that's what he was trying
to convey
uh that it's so extraordinarily unlikely
uh avenitio from
from first principles if you if you
weren't acculturated as we are
that that's what he was trying to say um
and it was
it's it's a it's a striking um
it's it it's striking and it sounds
facetious but
it was it was making a strong point that
if we were not so acculturated
from his point right now some people say
that you know the the belief in god is
acculturated in
all traditions around the world and
everybody sort of believes it naturally
and
and uh and it is uh a a
a basic belief of human beings this is
alvin planiga's famous
uh kind of argument about uh you don't
need you know when i interviewed hal of
one of my one of our segments we had
many many segments for that
30 here very appreciate that and one of
my
you know these segments these 10-minute
segments were arguments for god and i
said how
your point of view you believe in god he
said yes what do you think are the best
arguments
for the existence of god uh that was the
segment
and he said uh okay i'm gonna give you
some arguments but i first want to say
is i don't think you need arguments to
believe in god
and that you're fully justified
warranted you know honest in your
beliefs and
and fully rational to believe in god
without any arguments
now this is this was al's big
contribution one of his big
contributions to philosophy religion and
christian philosophy in particular
is to say that you could be a warranted
belief
in god without evidence and without
arguments
um and that the belief in god is similar
to the belief
and in the existence of the past like
you and i have been talking for
uh now two hours of
enjoyable time um and uh you know
did what we did in the first hour was
that real or or not well you and i both
believe
right the audience believes that what we
did in the first hour
really happened but you know how how do
we know that
how do we know that for sure well it's
sort of a basic belief
that we have and i believe that you know
i'm sent in my mind and
and i believe that you are as well
although you could be a philosophical
robot and have nothing inside just have
a lot of
stimuli and responses that's possible
but i believe in other minds so al's
point of view is that
if you believe in the existence of the
past and you believe in the existence of
other minds
you you should be able to believe in god
at the same level of confidence
without argument now one can argue that
wait why is that the case because
belief in god is what al would call a
basic belief
that is inculcated into human
beings in the same way that our belief
in the past is and so on
and we have belief in the past or belief
in other minds so our our concept of
belief in power
so he would say the level of belief in
god that you were entirely justified in
believing in god and being rational
etc um because it is so
uh intrinsic to uh to human sentience
uh that's his argument and it's a it's a
powerful and an important one
many people reject it of course um as
you know obviously i i've heard it and i
don't totally accept it yeah i don't see
why
i know you're not a defender of it i
don't see why it follows from the fact
that you believe in the past
and other minds that you then can
believe whatever intuitively comes to
you
it doesn't follow from it that's that's
not that's not the
that's the logic it is the same level of
uh of significance
it doesn't follow from the past of the
mind it just says with the same
confidence level that you have that
there was a past
the same confidence level that you have
in other minds
you should have that same confidence
level if somebody says they believe in
god you don't have to
subject them to proving
through the cosmological argument or the
ontological argument or the teleological
argument or
you know the fine-tuning argument any
argument you don't need any of those now
you may
want to enjoy thinking about those and
using those
but you don't need any of them that was
his argument i see
that you don't need arguments for god
again you can argue that
um but you know the importance is uh to
understand
uh the the nature of belief systems now
bead rondo
takes that same view exactly 180 degrees
opposite
that's why i brought it up so pete
rundle said the existence of god
is so unlikely and so absurd and so
ridiculous to have this
concept that if if somebody is healed
that we it's a real healing it's more
logical to have these aliens in a hidden
spaceship having done it rather than god
and and my my only point is i really
like these two guys
these are you know i love being with
them uh these are
you know i i didn't know dee rundle that
well
um but i enjoyed my time with him and al
planing is one of the great philosophers
and
we had wonderful sessions together and i
i treasure
but here they are absolutely opposite
on this point i mean so much so that
each
makes i can't i can't think of more
extreme
cases of being opposite where
one says belief in god you don't need
any arguments
for that it's just as basic to human
existence
as acknowledging there was a past
or that other minds exist and another
person saying
no matter what would happen no matter
what evidence
you would you could show me it doesn't
matter what you evidence you would show
me i will never
believe that the the the cause of that
evidence
is a god rather than some other kind of
explanation
and to me uh that
that to some people that would seem
terrible to have two smart people so
opposite
i think is wonderful i i i think it it
it's so
expressive of the of the human condition
and these are not people who
who don't think about these are people
to whom these questions are the
deepest part of their lives they've
devoted their entire lives to thinking
about these questions
and come up with such diverse answers uh
but when
when people do that when they have such
diversity
and such sophistication thinking about
topics like this i mean that's
core closer to truth and that's what we
try to bring to
to our audiences about
both of those arguments i want to tell
you what occurs to me i
again like i'm just a devil's advocate i
see flaws so
with alvin's position what occurs to me
is monotheism is relatively new
so if you go back fourth even 3000 years
then would that not be an argument for
polytheism rather than a belief in a god
that's what occurs to me okay so that's
number one and then for
bead grundle is that correct yeah for b
grundles again he's using
unless he's using the measure theoretic
definition of
probability which he's not because
that's actually you need many
many many many data points like in the
financial world in order to use that
then he's using a folk definition when
he's saying unlikely which means he's
using
propensity or subjective or or
frequentist and so on they're all flawed
so then one and then it also depends on
the drake equation which runs the gamut
from 100 certainty that extraterrestrial
intelligent life exists to
10 to the minus 400. you'd be making
vast assumptions there plus you're
making vast assumptions as to what
constitutes god
so i don't see why he could say with any
certainty that it's unlikely that it's
god or it's likely to be aliens
you're you're critiquing both positions
and i think that's uh
that's entirely uh justified um
i'm just looking at each one in its own
right um
and and why these people have come to
the view that they have and as i said i
i can't pick more diametrically opposite
views and that to me is fun i mean these
are the most
opposite views you can have one saying
you don't
you don't need any arguments for the
existence of god it is
properly basic in human psyche now
you can say that going back that it was
polytheistic and but
people always had this sense of
something beyond themselves i see i see
a lot of that uh but there's something
intrinsically basic
about this this belief on the one hand
on the other the other hand it's just
it's so absurd that um
virtually any other explanation uh would
be better
um that's just expressing two different
views that both of them
you know can be severely critiqued than
they are
and that and justify when we do that on
closer to truth that's fine
um but to to deposit these two
diametrically opposite views
is to me uh a very rich data point
in uh in assessing uh human
um sentience and cognizance and and
dealing with these big questions it's
extremely interesting
something that i think you would find
maybe you've thought about this
quite a bit why is it that these why is
it that brilliant people
obviously that depends on what you call
brilliant but why is it that
they disagree when they have access to
the same data
and they're not unless you want to say
that they're
biased now let's remove the bias because
well maybe you can't remove the bias
either way why do you think it is that
people disagree like noam chomsky versus
peterson or bernardo castro versus
virtually all of your guests why is it
that they disagree
is it that they have access to different
data
no i i think i think uh you know we
posit they have everybody has access to
the same data now
each has belief systems which are either
unconscious or developed culturally or
deliberately
manifest in terms of their own their own
study as they've had
but they bring different belief systems
and and that's why
you know we've we've run shows and the
universe is theologically ambiguous
religiously ambiguous because you're
able to take
these questions and and interpret the
data based upon your belief system
and i think that itself is a kind of
truth which is really important that we
can
we can agree upon so we can agree upon
the fact
that smart people take the same set
of externalities data
and come to radically different
conclusions about
the big questions that we deal with and
so that is a truth
and that is an absolute truth that's not
a relative truth that's a
a very clear absolute truth that's a
that's a fact of our world and i think
that fact of our world
is an important data point in
understanding our world
so it sounds like we've made no progress
because we've said that
some people believe one thing some
people believe in other but i
i would disagree i would say we have
made progress but because we see
that these people have made dramatically
different conclusions
based on the same set of the data and
these are
all smart people trained in science or
trained in philosophy or trained in a
logical way of thinking and they're
coming to different conclusions so that
is a
firm data point about existence
that you can see different
you can come to dramatically different
conclusions
even though people have the same
set of ways of thinking they're all
trained in the same system
and they and they have access to the
same external data
and so this is this is a this is a fact
of our world
and i think an important one and i think
it's one that is not a triviality i
think it's a it's an it's it's progress
to understand that
do you feel like you've gotten any
closer to truth
so my wife would say that she's a
pianist
um not not a scientist and not dealing
with these questions she said that when
we met which was now
uh how many years ago 54 55 years ago
congrats man
that she and i she
she and i were at the same kind of level
of knowledge about
things and now i've done um
you know 300 closer to truth shows and 4
000 interview questions
and she says we're still at the same
level of
understanding these questions even
though i've done uh
4 000 views and she's done none and i've
thought about this
for you know 50 years and intensely with
closer to truth the last 20 years and
she
doesn't think about these things at all
and we're both at the same level
there's a kind of truth in that in terms
of coming to an answer
but i think in reality um i have
a very deep appreciation for the nature
of the questions
i'm more excited about them than than
ever
um so it's not after talking to so many
people and hearing so many theories
you know i'm kind of fed up and i've
heard everything and no it's the
opposite it's just
you know it kind of luxuriating as i've
said in these
questions and appreciating the the depth
and the passion
um that people bring to them and new
ways of
new ways of addressing that's why i'm
closer to truth we will deal with the
same
question uh over and over again for
example why is this something rather
than nothing we call it the mystery of
existence
why not nothing uh what is the nature of
nothing
so we've had multiple shows people can
look that up on youtube or closer to
truth.com just put in
nothing and you'll see various shows
that we've done on that
many interviews it means put in the
actual quotation n-o
not put in nothing you won't get
anything yeah
n-o-t-h-i-n-g right exactly
uh and uh i don't know how we could code
for
literally putting in nothing um and then
um
uh nature of consciousness is
consciousness fundamental
uh what is the nature we've done so many
different ways because we have so many
different people to speak on these
issues and we've not exhausted it as you
mentioned
bernardo castro we look forward to
discussing with him as well
um in terms of the uh of the thinking so
it's you know you ask am i closer to
truth after all this time
i would say no in terms of an absolute
answer to questions
but certainly yes in terms of
appreciation of
what those answers would have to consist
of
what the nature of it is what the inner
structure of the question would be what
the uncertainties are
i feel that there's a very rich sense of
that and that
that is really getting closer to truth
and uh
we're so pleased to have so many viewers
come along with us on this
uh on this journey robert with all these
people you interview
are you able to keep their different
theories now they're extremely disparate
but are you able to keep them
alive in your head such that you can
allude to them or quote them
when you're speaking to another
interviewer and if so how do you do that
do you take notes
yeah i i um i don't consider myself to
having a
you know spectacular memory um i i
i am focused on each interview on that
person's way of thinking
and i bring to it my own um my own
perceptions of that question and and i
i do it from my perspective as
as informed of course by everything else
i've done
but i i generally don't try to trade one
um set of opinions against another i
won't i won't say to one person well
uh alvin planning has said or richard
swinburne said or stephen weinberg said
or michael shermer said i i i don't do
that
don't listen to anything michael
schumer's i do it for my own no i'm just
kidding he's a friend
i do it from my own perspective uh but
again as enriched and informed by all
the conversations that i've had but
i i try to focus on each individual to
try to get the best
thinking out of that person by having
them you know some free
association some probative questions
some
some questions to kind of uh
attack or undermine their position just
to get more out of them
uh so that's that's that's what i try to
do so each interview is is
done on its own its own focus not
in terms of uh what other people think
when we
when peter gets else and i put together
the shows then we
we synthesize kind of an artificial
architecture
where we'll take four to six generally
five
people and and have a series of excerpts
three
four minutes each and then with some
interstitials as we go from one to the
other so we develop
a secret a a story it's artificial and
looks like it's you know happy
interesting separately
chronologically but it's not it it
we developed the chronology the apparent
chronology in the show
based upon a a flow of ideas and
argument
as opposed to a real real world
chronology which
it can't be um peter is the editor
uh peter getzel is he's the jur he's the
producer director and then he has
editors working for him which are
wonderful editors uh and i i'm very much
involved in the
uh in the in the selection so i work
together with them on script basis but
not the visual basis the way the show
works they
do all the visuals by themselves but i'm
i'm i i
i select every word uh in in uh
and then make it has to work as a film
so it's it's a long and complicated
process and it's totally consumption
when we do a show with one show you know
a little under 27 minutes of airtime
uh it is uh it is every word every frame
is uh
is thought about worried about focused
on my whole world is that one show
and when it's gone i don't i don't think
about it again do you rather these
podcasts that are unedited where you
just put up the footage online or do you
actually enjoy the editing process
it's another expression which we had
which we which was not
in in my dna and it was not part of
closer to truth until we were
forced to do it last year because of the
lockdown and so now we have
three expressions of closer to the truth
we used to have two we had our
super polish shows which are our crown
jewels which are most proud of that
most of them are on youtube now and
closer to truth.com
that they'll all be up in the next few
months
uh releasing one one uh one a week now
or several several a week
um and we have the raw interviews which
are these seven to 12 minute sessions of
which we have
over four thousand maybe five thousand
by now of these
segments and those are also very highly
produced
and now what we've done in the last
years we have the same things that you
and i are doing here
for uh your uh a podcast theory of
everything which is great
uh we've done that for closer to truth
so we've done
you know 15 or so uh what we
what we're calling closer to truth chats
and sometimes we do it live and
sometimes we
most of the time we we don't and we have
a very wide
variety of people um you know we did dan
danette then on free will
and uh george smoot nobel prize winner
in cosmology
uh jill tarter on alien intelligences
uh lynn milad now just did a book on
stephen hawking
if someone wants to know when is your
correspondence with castro
going to be uh our plan is to do the
interview when we are shooting in the uk
next
year which will be in uh
planning for march of 2022 and we hope
to
schedule bernardo during that period of
time which would mean that the interview
would be
posted you know several months later
in uh in different segments uh because
when we
will hope to do you know 12 or so
segments
with bernardo and different ways of
approaching this topic it won't be
it won't be the kind of interview we're
doing here which is you know all
straight
they'll be in in segments and we'll post
the segments at that time and then
eventually those will find their way
into actual shows in which his views
will be contrasted with uh with others
i'll link to that in the description
once they're out just please
i'm pretty sure it'll get recommended to
me but if it doesn't send them to me and
i'll put it in the description of this
so if you're listening watching it's in
the description
okay someone named and by the way that
previous question came from panda
products
okay andrea s asks your favorite
question why does anything exist and how
has your thinking on this
changed um uh
you know the question of existence is
the the great question of uh
of uh of philosophy and indeed of
reality i've always said the
questions you know does god exist is
consciousness fundamental how did the
universe come about what about the
fundamental laws of physics life after
death these are all
super important big questions but i call
them second level questions the
primary question is why is there
anything at all
and um you know i had a
fascination of this when i was a
literally a child it
scared me so to think about it and i
thought it was unique and
over the years i found many people have
had that same experience that kind of
that uh that that feeling of
disassociation where you wonder what if
there were nothing
and it's a very scary uh scary thought
and
i've had the opportunity now over the
years to
develop this very very much in great
detail we've done
many shows on why is this something
rather than nothing what is nothing
why not nothing mystery of existence on
closer to truth dot com on closer to
youtube
but i have to give credit to one of our
early contributors
john leslie who is a
british canadian philosopher who
developed these ideas and
and other ideas in
developed the philosophy of cosmology as
well as a philosophy of existence
and john was was a great teacher
of mine i looked to him and very proud
to say we did a book together
um as a result of closer to truth it was
published in 2013 called the mystery of
existence
why is there anything at all in which
john was the lead editor and i was
happy to be editor with him and we uh
picked uh out of all human history
excerpts of the best thinkers
uh from plato onward uh to current
scientists etc dealing with the question
why is there something rather than
nothing and
um it's a very big topic
and an exciting one um i didn't know
plato had thoughts on that
yes uh i mean you could you could read
it
read it into it where plato believed
that
the good or value
was sort of a protogenitor of reality
that reality exists for the good
interesting
so you can read back into some people
are very specific like live units and
others
but others you could read into their
thinking of uh
of why things exist um
and i have uh uh on closer to truth.com
or
a piece called levels of nothing in
which i deal with
nine levels of nothing people talk about
nothing
they think they know what they mean why
isn't there not nothing
but in this piece i show that there are
nine ways
that nothing can be described so there
are nine levels of nothing
and what's fun to me is the nothing that
many physicists talk about the quantum
foam that
takes from nothing no space time no no
matter energy no no nothing and then
they you create a universe out of
nothing which many physicists believe
happened indeed may have happened that
way but that to me is my level
five nothing right because it presumes
the laws and so on
four levels of nothing less than that
in terms of what it is and let people
can look that up levels of nothing on
closer to truth.com
or nothing but this to me is the most
probative question
and the most exciting question uh you
know we know for sure there
is something you know but why that's the
case is uh
is a is a wonderful thing to delve into
neutrino a commenter i love says
robert i kind of love you
he also said well steve scully says
question for robert
just because something exists does this
necessarily preclude nothing from also
existing
yes i think it does some people would
would argue that
and many people said this and maybe when
you have your tetralemma theory of logic
you can have nothing and
something at the same time but i in my
simplicity
would say once you admit there is
something in one possible world out of
an infinite number
then by my definition there is something
and so once there is
something there can never have been
nothing in in the in the big sense so
once you admit
any kind of something in any kind of
possible world anyway
you've you've answered the question that
there is that there is not nothing
uh and that's pretty much uh you know
digital
on off uh the way i think about it that
doesn't mean
if you have something it can go back to
nothing
but if you have something that they will
never be the case ever
that there was never anything there was
always nothing
if you had something at one point then
there was something
last two pj wants to know about your
thoughts on ufo sightings and counters
seems to previously be getting laughed
at but increasingly taken more seriously
and then someone wants to know what your
thoughts are on life after death
pandaproducts wants to knows that so pj
what are your thoughts on ufo
experiences sightings and counters
yeah we do not deal with those kinds of
questions traditionally on
closer to truth i would also put another
category which we're asked about
even more often than ufos is a
near-death experiences
right great panda products these are not
categories we've
dealt with a little bit um but
these are the kinds of questions that
lend itself to kind of factual and
technical analysis
esp and parapsychology is another
category
that lends itself to these kind of
factual statistics and we don't we don't
deal with that
we have done with esp and parapsychology
the implications
so if parapsychology and esp are true
and we would define what that means
real phenomena in some sense uh what
would that imply
what would what would that imply about
the nature of mind or physical it's
all different that's a legitimate closer
to truth area but
not to determine the statistical proofs
or not proofs of that that's that's not
what we would do
i put ufos in that same category i
personally would be a skeptic but i
don't consider myself
um sufficiently knowledgeable and i i
have noticed there has been more
attention lately to those kinds of
questions
you know they're all multiple answers
to that kind of question much like there
is to uh the fermi paradox of why we
don't see aliens there are
dozens and dozens of possible
explanations so
but um you know i i would remain
a skeptic on on ufos if ufos are
deliberately um uh i mean are
representative of alien civilizations uh
so far advanced uh
uh there was an article in the new
yorker about this recently and
i like the line because nobody addresses
why they're so advanced that so many
seem to crash
in area 51 if they're so advanced but
so i'm i'm pretty much a skeptic uh up
on that
as far as life after death um
i i think this is a uh this is a closer
to truth uh topic we deal with this a
lot
it obviously has to deal with uh the
nature of consciousness
and if consciousness is 100 physical
then there is no life after death um
if uh consciousness is something beyond
that
or if there is a non-physical
existence such as uh you know
traditional gods or some type of
spiritual realm
then there is a possibility of that i've
dealt with this in a
paper on uh an article i've written on
virtual immortality
yeah i write that one thank you for
sending that and
it's the diverse explanations of
consciousness
from pure materialism to
epiphenomenalism to what's called
non non-reductive physicalism
where it is physicalism but there's
something beyond that so quantum
theories of consciousness the different
aspects of qualia
to um to dualism
and ultimately idealism where everything
is consciousness or cosmic consciousness
and each of these have different
implications
about the nature of life after death as
well as
the possibility of uploading our first
person consciousness
into another medium which what i call
the techno optimists in silicon valley a
lot of people
assume that that is that is uh in a
hundred percent uh certainty it's just a
question of technology
and i would argue that's not the case it
it
to to to upload your first person uh
consciousness um is a deep philosophical
question it's not a i mean it's also
technological and
it would take me thousands of years to
be able to develop a technology not
decades or something but
even if you had the technology you
really have to discern what the nature
of consciousness is before you can do
that so questions of
of um of life after death
questions of uh uploading your
consciousness and questions of ai
super ai consciousness those are three
separate questions life after death um
uploading your own consciousness into
another medium and attaining some kind
of immortality
and ai super ai consciousness are they
kind of those are three separate
questions and i argue that they are the
same question
that you have that all three of them are
based
are founded on the same question which
is the the nature of consciousness you
can't answer any of those
you can't assume that you know the
answer to any of those unless you
have a prior um belief in a certain
theory of consciousness
robert had to go but luckily he was
gracious enough to answer some of the
questions over email
some listeners wanted to know what are
robert's thoughts on the demarcation
problem
robert said this the key test is
repeatability
an important probative question the next
question comes from abdullah khalid
could robert tell us about his best
interview experience
robert says which of your children do
you like best
if you picked a quote unquote best how
would others feel
another question viewers listeners asked
was who would you interview of the past
if you could robert says pascal
the next question comes from mj mcgoven
this one comes from the theories of
everything discord
i would be curious how robert kuhn
splits his time between his activities
what are some of the more surprising
things he's learned through his career
and if he has any advice for people who
want to follow in his footsteps like
maybe kurt
that reminded me by the way that i
wanted to ask robert kuhn what advice he
has for me
building theories of everything as a
combination of my quest to explicate
theories
as well as to build a community around
theories of everything
and as well as for me and the community
to advance the state of theories of
everything
in general robert kuhn said this
pursue your passion closer to truth its
ideas
has been my lifelong passion china for
came about accidentally some 33 years
ago
by the capriciousness of the world as it
were and it became a grafted-on passion
both closer to truth and closer to china
are based on my deep desire to learn and
to share what i've learned
the process as well as the content my
advice
keep doing what you're doing do what
works best for you
don't try to target demographics let me
know your progress
all the best robert
okay that was a marathon man that's
where we leave it
robert thank you so much it was a
pleasure it's it's still a pleasure
and it's a bit surreal although i'm
by the end of it now i've acclimated to
it but to see you because
when i was younger before i even started
theories of everything or a podcast
i would watch your videos and i found
them incredibly insightful
and i'm i'm fairly certain
much of what i think has been
unconsciously
and somewhat consciously to influenced
by you and
your show so thank you so much for
there's many people here in the chat
that is saying that they love you and
thank you as well
great girl enjoyed being in
congratulations on theory of everything
i think it's a it's a real contribution
and
we're on this journey together that's
for sure man
have a great one bye bye
you